football season is upon us folks Jeffrey
Epstein is out of the news we're moving
on
you like winning money of course you do
you like betting sports of course you do
what else are you gonna do with your
life I'll tell you where I put my money
down my bookie dot AG you can bet on the
NFL baseball MMA whatever my bookies got
it they've got better incentives and
more lines and any other supports put
period okay they got everything they
have these uh all kinds of like
non-traditional bats dude that are
pretty cool a prop that you can bet on
something unconventional you get bet on
like Trump resigning which will never
happen but you could bet 100 bucks and
you'll win 1200 you know there's 12 to
one odds like these are fun bets will
come up with a few of those bats you
know we could do like you know you could
bet that just Lane Maxwell would be
arrested which obviously she's not gonna
be but you could do bets like that it
doesn't have to be sports but listen
they're great at sports and I'm telling
you this right now folks my pick right
now okay I'm gonna say Monday Night
Football Chicago and Washington I say
the Bears minus four and uh under
Redskins team total 19th I don't really
give it I don't know I know everything
about this my friend Michael is picking
these out because he's like a degenerate
gambler and he like ran like a service
where like people would bet with him and
he's like that kind of guy he's like a
slimy guy so he knows about this so he's
giving me my picks you know I don't
really give a [ __ ] about sports I'll do
some other fun bets
you know like society collapses when
here we go folks I'm gonna say it again
bears minus four and under Redskins team
total which is nineteen okay
bet that Reds can suck they have a
racist name and their owners a
billionaire [ __ ] okay my friend is
really good
these pics by the way he's not bad at
them you know I'm telling you he's gonna
be really helping me out in this in this
until I really get until I get a little
better at it because he's from that
world he's in that world okay
well it's important to me that I give
you guys the information that you need
so that you can go and bat they just
revamp their site my book if you've been
on my book II been yeah I've used it I
encourage shut up I encourage you all of
you to go and take a look if you haven't
already okay it's fun to bet on things
it is fun to gamble I remember I went to
a bachelor party with a friend of mine
we went to Atlantic City which is really
like a Disney World for chain-smoking
amputees and it's really really bad my
friend Mike Lawrence made a great point
it goes these people think they're gonna
be lucky they all have like their
missing limbs they're gonna be lucky now
it was interesting we went to Show Boat
casino which was like this horrific kind
of racist like you know themed casino in
Atlantic City that was going out of
business right next to Trump's cuz you
know which was also kind of going out of
business people are just you know if
doing heroin in the bathrooms and you
know there's rats running around but the
I mean I was playing I think three-card
poker we're just having a good time it's
fun to gamble and it's much more fun to
gamble and not leave your house that's
the move here you can win money you got
my audience can do it you can do it you
can win why don't you win why don't you
go and be somebody stop listen if your
fiancee run her mouth go and take life
by the [ __ ] balls make a little money
and then you tell her where you're going
on vacation okay you know she's
disgusted with you cuz you don't have
the kind of money that her friends men
do you know she's got to talk about how
funny you are at brunch with those other
birds
it's disgusting we in a little bit a
little money tell you right now that's
the way to do it
and don't do it in a traditional way who
cares the working man is a sucker don't
be a sucker
take all of the money that you earn and
bet okay double your first deposit now
if you use promo code Tim you get 100
percent bonus on your initial deposit up
to $1,000 if you deposit 500 you get a
thousand if you deposit a thousand you
get 2,000 don't be stupid folks if you
like to bet this is the site to bet 100%
and if you don't like to bet you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and and nobody respects you
you have a soft penis it never gets hard
and your wife stands there waiting and
then she goes into masturbates in the
bathroom because she cannot she can she
married this [ __ ] [ __ ] that is afraid
to go out there and take a chance you're
afraid to risk okay I'm telling you the
Bears are gonna win Monday night I've
looked at the spreads and the statistics
and I've I've done the work I've done my
due diligence okay the Bears have a
great team they got uh that the big guy
and then the few other ones they're
gonna [ __ ] win what is the Redskins
got what are they got they got nothing
they got a bunch of Nazis running around
that they're they're they they they
they're their name is the Washington
Redskins that's that's a real name you
imagine that's a name that's ridiculous
what are you gonna wear I mean what kind
of what kind of organization would
tolerate that they should change their
name to the Washington intersectional
feminists or something that's respectful
and and positive like the Washington you
know Native American alliance I don't
know but it's what do you think about
the game you're ready for the game
the Bears I'm ready I'm ready I'm going
for it on the Bears are the well
everybody loves the big guy he's already
Saget bad every
says Ben's gay and I tried to let him
let him defend themselves by having some
sports knowledge and of course he's got
calming his throat he can't say me he's
like I'm betting on the PGA Tour
tomorrow
oh the PGA Tour that's good you bone
smoking queer [ __ ] can't watch
football you know he can only come of
his chick Fox him okay say my twink
seems gay you [ __ ]
alright folks I can say I could say the
word [ __ ] because I'm a black gay man
double your first deposit now folks
who's even thinking about this get in
there and start betting if you enjoy my
show if you have the balls to make
something if you want to win get in
there that's my bookie my B oh okay ie
don't forget to use the promo code Tim T
I am when creating your account to claim
the bonus TI M is the way you claim your
bonus deposit 200 bucks you get 400 you
play around you have some fun report in
show me that you've won show me that
you've won we'll talk about it on the
show we'll talk about you on the show
well bring you out to LA you'll be
famous
I'm telling you win a few games at my
bookie I'll bring you out to LA I'll get
you a movie deal and then make a movie
about your interesting life
okay I'm so excited for this game on
Monday you know I look like a guy that
really wants to always talk about people
come up to me and talk about football me
all the time I just stare at them I
don't really watch football but I have
the I look like a guy that would care a
lot about football so when people come
up to me they're like they say stuff and
I'm just like yeah yeah wow you know
what it is now it's a different game so
times if I'm in a football conversation
and I don't know what to say
I saved myself by go hey [ __ ] Colin
Kaepernick so people understand that
even the football is important it's more
important to be racist you know what I
mean so that's a great way to get
yourself out of a football conversation
is to just steer it into racist waters
that's my bookie and I'm not a racist
I'm just saying sometimes in order and I
think Colin Kaepernick is great I think
he's fine but in order to get out of a
technical conversation about sports I
have to I have to you know Stewart
towards that my bookie my B oh okay ie
Michael Michael is making the bets here
so if you don't win you will win because
Michael is a legit dirtbag like he is a
legitimate dirtbag 100% like is a
garbage person [ __ ] he cares about
sports and a long time ago he was you
know like you know hookers and sports
and cool [ __ ] I respect that
everybody loves [ __ ] by the way what
are you nuts every person you respect
loves horse okay every [ __ ] fun
little comedian or actor you think you
think they're like wholesome let me tell
you right now they're whipping someone
in a hotel room my bookie my B oh okay i
e.com Tim will double your money get in
there and win teach your kids out of
gamble
life is about chance everything is
gambling the economy is gambling risk
reward do you get that
dum dum take a risk stop going to
college and to get on loans and getting
degrees you failure you know that adds
up to [ __ ] the guys are really made to
take risks take chances I know a lot of
people that have gambled in one you can
always get back up dust yourself off and
win again I
people that are addicted to gambling or
they think they're kind of addicted to
losing because it's like that great
feeling of just being like I'm bottomed
out but I can guys got nowhere to go but
up
[Music]
that's what I want for you all of you I
want you to feel that feeling you have
nowhere to go but up you're gonna win
tim is a promo code if you enjoy my show
and you want to [ __ ] around if you're a
man with a big penis that you put
wherever you want with consent and
everybody's happy about it you've got
that kind of penis if you if you're a
weird man a beta male and you don't have
a penis maybe even then maybe don't you
know but if you are a man you better you
and you're a woman too if you're a woman
or a man I mean bloody the audience is
men so not gonna be an idiot here and
start you know act like I have an
audience of a ton of women I don't
some of them listen I respect their
intelligent one let's be honest the
women listen to show a little
intelligent and a lot of them out there
are not let's be honest and I'm not
saying I'm not saying there's a lot of
men that aren't intelligent too but the
women that Alysha show they're on a
higher vibrational plane than the rest
of them that's it sorry
same with the gay people is in this show
men anyone who's listening this show you
want a higher vibrational plane than the
rest of society you're you are better
than they are and that's why you should
gamble okay because you got it they
don't got it you got it
my B oh okay I e.com Tim use promo code
Tim if you like my show and you want to
take a chance get in there and and make
me proud make your daddy proud make your
wife and kids proud and win some goddamn
money for Christ